first combine softened butter and sugar
and cream it'll soft breaking an egg and
mix well next folding the flour pour the
mixture onto a floured surface and
simply knead it lightly till it's well
combined then shape into a disk and
chill then simply roll out your pastry
until it's about a quarter of a
centimeter thick cut into small disks
then gently press into lightly greased
lose bottom mini tart tins and prick the
bottom to prevent the pastry from
bubbling breast in the fridge this
ensures that when the pastry base it
will turn out nice and soft then bake it
till golden as they cool made the
gorgeous silky chocolate filling
place a mixing bowl over a pan of gently
boiling water this is known as a ban
Marie then add double cream butter and
plain chocolate then stir until it melts
and is glossy and smooth then pour it
into the crisp and golden pastry cases
and simply tap to level and chill until
set
so easy so indulgent and so delicious
eat them with crème fraîche ice cream or
simply by themselves perfect mix Dijon
mustard white wine vinegar olive oil and
saffron nice large thick slices the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish